good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation I think I'm being
amplified you know government saw is
somewhat broken governing Nance is the
long term few governments come and go
but governor Nance this kind of slow
process but it may be one of those kinds
of evolution that's periodic and so
things don't seem to change for a long
time and then they need to change and
they do so the government's are all
slightly broken and they're all slightly
repairing themselves but from time to
time they get so broken that bigger
things happen and you want those bigger
things not to be a Russian Revolution
which breaks everything but it's
something more like a hundred years is
Phillip K Howard
Thank You Stuart and thank you all for
for for coming this evening and I
especially thank Alan and toven for
coming and wearing a tie so I'm not the
only person I'm from New York and I
sleep in attack the before we dive into
the to what many view is this slimy
quicksand of government I think it's
useful to remember who we are we are
citizens of the most successful most
progressive country in history the
country still has the strongest economy
in the world we still have a can-do
spirit that's manifested in many places
but especially in this part of the world
where there's so much creativity that's
gone on over a period of my entire
lifetime we're people who have a can-do
spirit we can solve problems in our own
business and our own lives and there's
no reason in the world why we can't
solve the problems that we see in
government as long as we share a vision
of what a healthy democracy should look
like and we come together behind that
vision now I think we all probably or
most of us would agree there's something
seriously wrong with government this was
the first time in history that Americans
feel that our children's lives will be
worse off than then in our lives it's
odd that we feel that way because we
don't face an immediate peril it's more
like the quiet before the storm there's
a sense that we're adrift as a society
and around the bend there might be some
precipice that we're gonna fall off of
we don't know whether it's going to
happen next year or in five years but
there's this looming sense of disaster
and there's no confidence at all in the
public that government can fix what's
wrong and indeed there's every
confidence that government is a big part
of the problem I also think there's no
problem no confidence in our political
parties my own view is that both parties
are broken
Republicans as you know have this mantra
of no new taxes which they advanced
repeatedly and boringly without any plan
to cut government expenditures so we
might be able to balance the budget it's
just no new taxes as if taxes were
independent of how much we spend
Democrats continue to expand
entitlements for perfectly legitimate
reasons except without a plan to meet
have our means meet our budget as well
so so neither party is doing what's
needed I have a friend who runs the
progressive Policy Institute will
Marshall who recently said it's not true
that bipartisanship is dead in America
there's a perfect bipartisan conspiracy
to bankrupt the country so we see this
we see this happening but we feel
powerless to do anything about it we see
this drift the odd thing is if you talk
to a political leader a senator or
members of Congress they'll see it too
and they too will say that they feel
powerless to do anything about it so we
have this odd situation where the people
we elect to be in power themselves feel
powerless and we all see the same drift
so what I'd like to do in a few minutes
this evening and hopefully follow it up
with Q&A is to give what I think is the
diagnosis to talk about some proposals
that might work or might not work and
then ultimately come up with my solution
which is three fundamental changes in
the structure of our government that
would restore a kind of sense of
responsibility and and the ability to
function
so first the diagnosis we feel powerless
because we are powerless the political
leaders feel powerless because they are
powerless they're powerless because
we're all powerless because we're
strangled by laws of our own making if
you look at an x-ray of a state Capitol
or Washington you see how these
wonderful government money
and it looks good if you look at the
picture but if you look at the x-ray
you'll see a web of law and regulation
that's gotten denser and denser over the
course of our lives that looks like an
impenetrable jungle it is hard to do
anything in this web I was talking to
Stephen goldsmith recently who's the new
deputy mayor for operations of the city
of New York he had previously been mayor
of Indianapolis where he was very
successful as an innovator in in in good
government
I said well how's it going and he said
well I've had eight really good ideas
about how to make the government of New
York City work more effectively
unfortunately each one of them has been
illegal it's almost impossible to build
and important to create a green
environmentally environm mental
infrastructure because the way law works
it takes a decade or sometimes two
decades to do a project last year wind
farm was approved off the coast of
Massachusetts after ten years of study
by 17 different agencies ten years I
mean it's not that complicated
the next day 12 lawsuits were filed to
stop the project claiming yes inadequate
review that will take another three or
four years to wind its way through
through the courts balancing a budget
andrew cuomo's the new governor of New
York he goes into Albany he finds that
75% of the budget has been set in legal
concrete and mandates and entitlements
and contracts agreed to by political
leaders many of whom are long dead he
has to balance the budget on the other
25% I had a talk with dick Reardon
former mayor of LA about how LA was
going to balance it but its budget same
problem they're going to balance it off
the backs of schools and parks because
those are two of the only items where
the mayor actually has
discretion given all the other mandates
from the state and federal government
they have to comply with we don't
normally think of public schools as a
legal problem but in fact public schools
are crushed by bureaucracy a 2007 study
in California of why good teachers quit
the California public school system
found that one of the first reasons was
a perceived powerlessness to do what
makes sense because they had to spend
their day complying with what they
thought were senseless rules and filling
out senseless forms the group I chair
common good did a study a few years ago
of all the rules that apply to one when
one school in New York City turned out
no one had ever compiled there's
thousands of rules and laws from all
sorts of from all levels of government
you've never heard of that applied no
one could possibly know all the
regulations so maybe the reason no one
ever compiled it so one of the things we
did we tried to do chart so well if you
really wanted to comply with the law
what it would require so one of the
charts we did was how many legal steps
and considerations there were to suspend
a student remember
when you suspend a student you're not
sending the kid to jail you're sending
him home well here is the chart that we
came up with on all the legal steps and
considerations to suspend a student in
the New York City school system no one
could possibly exactly no one could
possibly comply with this so then we say
well maybe New York City is an outlier
so we did the same studies in Denver
exactly the same results and it ripples
into society you know that if there's
all this regulation in government then
pretty soon anyone who wants to start a
small business for example well
essentially it's impossible to start a
small business and comply with all the
law because you couldn't afford the
lawyer to tell you what all the law was
there was a report this past weekend
about a couple who wanted to start a
cupcake store in Maryland turned out
they thought they could
but then the the requirements kept
piling up fine first there was the
grease trap then the triple sink and all
these other requirements that might have
made sense for a larger food service
establishment but not for a 15 foot wide
little cupcakes and so finally finally
they gave up and I think it's hard to
imagine how powerless people within
government feel and what the culture of
government is like and while
government's a big entity there are 20
million people in America who worked for
government and there are fantastic civil
servants I think we should say who keep
the trains running on time and deserve
our undying gratitude for the work they
do the culture overall is pretty sick
and people are trained not to use their
common sense former governor of New
Jersey Tom Kane told me the story on his
first day in office as governor he went
to the his office in the state capitol
and Trenton found that his light bulb
was out he asked the state trooper on
duty if he could find him a lipo state
trooper went ten minutes ago by 20
minutes ago by finally the trooper comes
back and says I found the light bulbs
right away because I couldn't bring it
up because I couldn't find a requisition
form think about that you could leave a
post-it saying got a light bulb for the
governor but he couldn't bring it up so
Tom Kane went and got the light bulb out
of his lawyer's office and left his
lawyer without the lipo so what happens
in all of these stories is that we seem
to have the wrong idea of the rule of
law we've been taught to respect the
Constitution and the rule of law and we
think of you know contract law and all
the wonderful things about the rule of
law but all the programs and the
examples I just gave are not timeless
principles of right and wrong like you
can't steal someone's property or you
have to respect contracts there's simply
ways of managing a complex
interdependent society to provide
services whether it's school
to approve reasonable approval for
environmentally important projects and
the like
the point of those programs is to manage
society sensibly but the effect of those
programs the way they're written is to
prevent the people we elect or a point
from managing government sensibly
and so over the course of our lives
what's happened is that law is piled up
like sediment in the harbor and it's
gotten to the point where no one can get
anywhere basically and if you had to
look at sort of who's making the
decisions you would have to say well
democracy is actually run by dead people
it's all these people who pass these
laws and wrote these rules over the last
30 40 or 50 years
it's like central planning except that
the planners are no longer with us so
it's actually a little worse than
central planning so we have this system
where people feel powerless because they
are for this all this law that prevents
people from using your judgement so
what's the solution to this now one the
Conservatives say the solution is
deregulation there's too much government
we need to deregulate get rid of get
government off our backs and that's the
that's very attractive to to adherents
of the Tea Party I'm sure there are many
of you here tonight like that and there
certainly are a number of vestigial
programs and we'll talk about that that
that we could we could do without but
the reality is is in a global
interdependent anonymous economy we need
government for our freedom we need all
these regulatory red lights and green
lights I don't know who put whether
there's LED paint on the toys that go to
my grandchild or not you know I don't
know who's whether the water is clean or
the where the air is pure somebody has
to be a surrogate for us to to safeguard
all these common Goods and that's the
role of
government so government's not going to
become less important it's going to
become more important
the smaller the world becomes the other
solution and I've worked on a number of
these projects is what's known as
regulatory reform President Obama had an
op-ed today announcing an exhaust
eternal announcing a new executive order
for regulatory reform where he's going
to appoint officials from each agency to
go through the agencies and to get the
rid of dumb rules and to allow the get
rid of dumb rules and allow people to
use their common sense we want we don't
want dumb rules anymore and he's going
to go out and clean it out the most in
bishops of those programs was Al Gore's
reinventing government program with
which I was involved and it was
incredibly ambitious in scope we went
across the agencies we worked hard on on
streamlining environmental reviews we
worked on procurement reform and those
reforms were still in place to to stop
wasting so much money and you know one
point they had rules for for buying
computers that by the time the computers
arrived there were five generations old
because they took so much time to create
incredibly idiotic rules was very
ambitious and to a great degree
successful but all of those programs
either snip stupid legal vines or they
create clearings in this big
bureaucratic jungle but none of them
have actually taken on the jungle itself
and what I've come to understand after
working on probably a dozen of these
with with governors mayors and two
presidents so far is that we're never
going to make government work
effectively in fact it's going to get
more paralyzed because of the inevitable
growth of law until we take on the
jungle because the reality is is that
the more significant that is given the
decision whether it's the bed
the budget or to prove environmental
projects and such the more flexibility
is required so a governor has to balance
the budget had to make cuts across the
board
he can't be limited as the mayor of LA
is to two schools and Parks well that
requires an open framework that allows
cutting not a framework where you're
faced with with walls of legal mandates
that are decades old the same thing with
an environmental project some official
actually has to have the authority to
say go after a year or two you can have
a check or a balance in that but
somebody has to say we've reviewed the
effects of the wind farms and concluded
that on balance it's important it's more
important for society to let this go
forward therefore I approve it we could
have some check and balance to that and
that's it
the interstate highway system was
authorized in 1956 and 15 years later it
was done or substantially done today the
environmental review process wouldn't be
done run a school same thing principals
and teachers need to have the same
freedoms that people and parochial
schools and charter schools have they
have to be free to be themselves in to
focus on the students not spend their
day worrying about filling and filling
out forms so I think the solution is not
deregulation it's not just regulatory
reform I think America needs a new
operating system and the operating
system basically would be to replace
bureaucracy with individual
responsibility where you pull back law
and law becomes a framework for goals
and sets principles but allows
individuals to actually in government to
actually take responsibility for making
sense of those goals and then are
accountable for whether they do a good
job this is not the first time in
history we've had to have it had to had
a change in our operating system it's
the fourth time since the Industrial
Revolution we had the progressive era
where we abandon what was gospel which
was less a fair because we discovered
you couldn't trust companies not to
mangle
child labor that in the New Deal we
realized we had to have social safety
nets because the global economic trends
were causing farmers to starve for
reasons well beyond their control and
then in the 60s we had the rights
revolution we discovered all these
abuses of racism and gender
discrimination and pollution and other
other abuses that needed to get fixed
and so we fixed them we're now at one of
those points in history where we have to
make another one of those changes but
now it's not a change of right and wrong
it's a change to make things work again
because we have a paralyzed government
so in order to do this I think there's a
a truism that I think it's a truism and
if you accept it you'll probably go with
me if you don't accept it perhaps you
want and the truism is this only real
people not rules make anything happen
nothing in life is accomplished by
following rules or filling out forms or
complying and this is true in government
as it is in any other life activity and
if we don't create a framework that
allows the real people within government
the responsibility to make choices it's
never going to work getting there
requires us to adopt three new
principles of organization for modern
government and each of these requires us
to toss overboard
a sacred cow that everyone takes for
granted the first one is that we need to
do a spring cleaning of all the law or
all the law that has budgetary
implications on the books it's not to
get rid of the law but to make it work
better today Congress doesn't even have
the idea that that it's responsibility
is to see how old law works it just
keeps piling up new laws like the recent
health care bill 2700 pages I mean that
itself is another subject to discussion
on top of thousands of pages of existing
top of existing law they wouldn't go
back and talk about the existing law
because that might have said somebody so
they have this idea that once law is
forged in the crucible of democracy it
should be treated as if it's one of the
Ten Commandments except it's one of the
10 million commandments it doesn't work
and the effect is all this old law is
like a millstone around our necks there
are subsidies from the New Deal probably
on the order of 50 to 60 billion dollars
a year worth so farm subsidies for
example cost fifteen billion dollars
they were enacted in the New Deal when
25% of the country lived on farms they
were in danger of starving so we created
these subsidies now 2% of the country
lived on farm live on farms most of the
farms the big farms who get those
subsidies are owned by corporations
there's no danger of starvation yet
we're still spending 15 billion dollars
a year that's a hundred thousand
families who pay each $15,000 a year in
taxes having all that money funnel out
to mainly corporate farmers who own the
system often there are laws that serve
very important goals but have taken a
life for their own and need to be
modified special education laws very
important we need to take care of
special needs children but they've
ballooned into something no-one ever
anticipated
now comprising over 20% of the total
budget of K to 12 education in this
country it's crazy it's twice what it
should be twice what other progressive
socialists leanin countries spend
providing good care for special needs
children it needs to be reconsidered and
rethought not abandoned simply but just
made just made sensible one law one
change in law would actually help make
Congress give it this idea and that's to
create an omnibus sunset law and under
this will basically all law
with budgetary implications would expire
after 10 or 15 years and what that does
is it makes Congress deliberately act
for the law to continue that in turn
gives reformers an opportunity to say
this law isn't working very well this
money could be better spent somewhere
else because and again Congress doesn't
acknowledge this every public dollar
involves a moral choice if you spend it
there it's not available here if you
spend it on necessary farm subsidies and
it's not available for pre-k education
it's it's absolutely a fixed law of
equivalents and yet Congress doesn't
even take the responsibility so number
one is we need to have the spring
cleaning probably with a sunset law on
top of it to make sure that Congress
continually revisits old laws the second
change is that law should be radically
simplified law today is incomprehensible
you could throw a dart at any law any
statute book any regulation and pick it
up and you will see levels of detail
that make no sense within 15 days after
receiving an application and 8 days
thereafter you shall and the forum it's
all about implementation you could get
rid of 95% of the words of law there are
about a hundred million words of binding
federal law at this point you can get
rid of 95% of them and change none of
the substance of the programs the
Constitution of the United States a very
important and generally effective
document is 16 pages long the law of
monopolization also generally effective
Sherman Act section two is eight lines
long the interstate highway Act
authorizing the most significant public
works in our country's history is 29
pages long there's no reason we have to
write laws that are 2700 pages that that
no one can ever read you say well how
can you simplify it it's easy you
replace all the detail with individual
responsibilities you have law set goals
have general principles you allocate
budgets
and you asked the department head to
report back every year or every six
months or whatever you want after I
wrote my first book the death of common
sense I was very critical of the worker
safety agencies known as OSHA so I was
summoned in to talk to the Secretary of
Labor and the senior senior officials at
OSHA to talk about why I was so critical
then they said they called me in was in
this big room and they said well what do
you want I said well I think you ought
to focus on safety not on compliance
with thousands of rules because studies
show that it doesn't do any good it
hasn't affected safety to make people go
around with their nose of the rule books
but what really does affect safety is
creating a culture of safety and judging
people by by by how well they train
their workers and such and they said
well we but what would you do with all
the rules I said well I you have 4,000
rules that specify exactly what kind of
tools and equipments used where railings
have to be exactly 42 inches high at one
point there were 40 rules on wooden
ladders 4,000 rules I said all of those
rules could be like one sentence they
said you've got to be kidding me
I said no no tools and equipment shall
be reasonably suited for the use
intended in accord with industry
standards I paused I said well that's
sort of an idea then talked about it and
and they said yeah but but but then
people won't know exactly what to do and
I said well maybe there'll be some
disagreement at the edges but let's just
give the presumption to your agency so
if there is a reasonable argument you
win but by and large people know what
that means there are industry standards
for things and that means that the the
guy in an office who has a dime-store
hammer to put pictures up on his wall
doesn't get a fine which he got
yesterday for not having an industrial
strength that hammer because he's not
using it to build a house and using it
to tack pictures on his wall let people
use her common sense they said no we
can't do it because people need to know
exactly what to do so I said okay well
ask let me ask another question how many
of you who have ever read the rules
there were like 30 people in this room
nobody raised their hand I said well
that's not surprising
I can guarantee you no form and it's
ever read the rules and certainly no
workers so what good are they nobody's
ever read them there's just a bunch of
tripwires that allow people to give you
tickets so why don't you go to something
that you know lets people use their
judgment and common sense and they can
understand anyway the meeting didn't end
up that well and but in fact the person
who runs OSHA ended up becoming a really
good friend and initiated all these
programs they didn't get rid of the
rules and they're back to enforcing him
now traffic cops but the but he
initiated all these programs where they
enforce the law based on actual safety
in the culture of safety and it worked
much better actual you know accident
rates went down in the areas where they
did these these projects so you can
actually make law work well if you focus
on the public goal and you give people
responsibility to try to implement it so
to summarize the second point of
simplified law there are these three
really important virtues the simple law
people can understand it it actually
allows you to go back and rewrite all
the bad laws to make them sensible
because you can never rewrite 2700 pages
times a thousand laws that would take
you know a thousand lifetimes but you
could write a bunch of fifteen and
twenty and thirty and forty page laws
and the final virtue of simplified law
is it gives people a chance to use their
judgment absolutely critical because it
pulls law away into a framework which is
what law is supposed to be the third
change then this is if anything the
biggest change is that public employees
have to be accountable
today accountability in government is
virtually non-existent
at least for tip for political in
employees most workers are not
accountable
you can never have a system like the one
I just described that gives officials
the authority to use their judgment
without accountability it's like a law
of organizational physics there's no
need for detailed rules telling people
how to do their job if they can be
accountable if they do a bad job that's
why it's so important to get rid of
teacher tenure it's not because there's
so many bad teachers it's because if you
get rid of teacher tenure you can get
rid of all this horrible bureaucracy
that that is killing the teachers and
suffocating them you don't need the
bureaucracy telling teachers how to
teach a classroom if the ones that
aren't doing the job can simply be told
to go do something do something else in
life it's absolutely critical to
overhaul in government it's not
something except in the teacher context
it's not something that's even on the
table because there is a sacred cow here
it is more sacred than the other cow and
the cow here is that you can't subject
public employees even to the hint of
accountability from any political figure
because ultimately political figures run
these agencies that's what democracy is
about and if you do that the myth
continues we'll have a return of the
spoil system oh my god that'd be guys
with yellow plaid suits with rolls of
hundred-dollar bills and all kinds of
terrible things government will work
terribly it's hard to imagine that the
government could work worse but that's
the there's this kind of fiction that
keeps us there that we have to insulate
public employees from accountability to
avoid a return to the spoil system well
it turns out that that's a complete myth
of history the spoil system had nothing
to do with firing the spoil that mean
that the civil service system the civil
service system got rid of spoils by
creating a neutral hiring system so the
politician couldn't appoint his friends
or campaign supporters through a job but
the jobs were going to be hired by the
civil service commission people would be
hired on the basis
of Merit it's called the merit system
and nothing to do with firing they would
keep their jobs on the basis of merit so
if you went back to what the civil
service system was intended to do you
would have a system where you could
usually have neutral hiring there again
there are many really wonderful civils
to public servants and if they do the
job then fine but if they don't show up
for work or in there are all these cases
of felons who were not allowed to lose
their jobs because the tenure is
virtually virtually ironclad and what
happened with civil service has happens
with all special interests the civil the
special interests ended up capturing the
politicians within 20 years after civil
service reforms in 1881 what had
happened is that the they had figured
out how to make themselves indispensable
politically to the politicians so they
got legal reforms that that basically
insulated them from accountability later
they formed they they formed unions then
they became large campaign contributors
at this point they are the largest
campaign contributor public unions to
one of the parties I forget which one
the they become incredibly they it is
said that they own Sacramento said that
they own Albany I don't know if that's
literally true but you get the the the
sense of it and some of the deals that
they've made with this power have been
incredibly insidious and destructive
these sweetheart pension deals will
people retire at the age of 45 with a
lifetime of pension that's double
sometimes what their average
compensation was because they beef it up
with vacation pay in the last year and
and overtime and and and such so you get
all of these abuses because the people
who are supposed to be serving us some
of them have organized into these
powerful political entities that both
keep them from being accountable and
make them run government for their own
benefit the story came out last month
that there's a juvenile detention center
in New York State that cost fifty
million dollars a year to run where
there are no inmates why is it open
because there's a law put into place by
the public employee unions that says
that any state facility that has union
workers cannot be closed without a
lengthy process plus at least one year's
notice so the taxpayers lose 50 million
dollars at a minimum because of this
featherbedding law basically that nobody
noticed that a politician went along
with for short-term political gain
with long-term costs - to the common
good so I'm at the point where I'm
getting to my conclusion now I've given
what I think are three basic changes to
restore responsibility and I think it's
not surprising that we feel that our
government is adrift is not surprising
because people don't run free to take
responsibility there's no accountability
we've got a government that's basically
organized to fail and so we ask
ourselves well why have we put up with
this why have we have this system that
we see at working worse and worse and
now you know leaving us for the facing a
waterfall with some we're gonna plunge
over if we don't do something about it
and I'm afraid the villain here is found
in the mirror we've organized our
government to avoid bad choices anything
to avoid bad choices and this is the one
place where all sides come together
liberals are terrified that corporate
interests will use their power to squirm
out of legitimate regulatory obligations
so they want law to be as precise as
possible to put legal shackles on those
companies to make sure they can't get a
get away with anything
conservatives feel the same way except
they feel that about government
officials they want they don't want to
give government officials any authority
to
anything because the government
officials might end up acting
unreasonably and undoubtedly certain
some some will and who knows what will
happen if you give any measure of
discretion to a government official so
far better to have a legal system that
ties their hands specifically so they
can never exercise your discretion then
there are the public employees this kind
of shadow force that people don't really
really talk about it they really like
this system at least their leaders do I
think it's actually terrible for the
good public employees because it keeps
them from from taking the responsibility
they want to take but their leaders like
it because it means they can't be blamed
who is to blame now who's to blame the
government doesn't work no one that's
what Hannah Arendt said it's like the
blob the blob has taken over this giant
legal blob public employees can say well
we're just doing what the law requires
now we can't do it because the law
doesn't allow you to do it now you can't
build that power line or those wind
farms because the law doesn't cuz the
law doesn't allow it so who's to blame
there's no one and ultimately I think at
least a lot of the blame comes to us
we're so scared of bad choices we're so
paranoid of letting anybody make a bad
choice that in our society today no one
has the authority to make the good
choices so how do we actually make
something like this happen well we have
to take some smelling salts and wake up
and see it for what it is we have to
come together behind a vision and we
have to acknowledge that Washington and
Sacramento they're never going to make
these changes the last governor in this
state would have liked to have made
these changes the current governor would
probably like to make these changes but
he can't because he's surrounded by a
system he can't at the moment that
allows him to make those choices and he
won't be able to unless the public
mobilizes and organizes itself around a
vision demanding a dramatic overhaul of
government not to deregulate but to
restore responsibilities to restore the
ability of the governor to actually to
make choices needed needed to balance
the
my not-for-profit common good hired
recently hired the team that did Obama's
the web team that did Obama's campaign
in 2008 and what we're doing is trying
to build an online platform whose goal
is to change the agenda for the 2012
election I'm not going to support any
candidate or either side the point is
simply to raise as an issue the need for
the basic overhaul of government to make
it functional again and we think if we
get people behind this idea and they
have backbone and they tell political
leaders that they're not going to
support them unless they support this
change in government that will actually
find leaders in both parties who are
willing to stand up for overhaul but
they're not going to do it unless the
public organizes because it's too
radical and too dramatic and they're too
many political risks to say we need to
change the incentives in Medicare unless
there's a large group that says we have
to be responsible in every area of our
law to give the ability to actually
balance the budget know that we're going
to continue to get this baloney of no
new taxes and don't touch my
entitlements which is the path to the
the path to ruin for ourselves and
almost certainly for for our children so
we can make change this is America you
can do whatever you want but this change
is not going to happen while we watch
the news it's only going to happen
because we come together enforce it
thank you very much
let's go sit over here geez we should be
doing some fundraising for coming yeah I
thought I was that's what you promised
yeah like that do you have any good
anecdotes yeah so we get in an uproar
quite rightly I you know this is bad and
this teacher thing is bad and the green
infrastructure is tough and and where do
you find inspiration either in history
or in a warm spot shortly they're good
things right Justinian was a really good
friend of mine and back in about 500 AD
he he decided that in this case it was a
mess of too much law but it was it was
judicial decisions in the Roman Empire
that he was going to clean it up and so
he got three guys with pointy hats and
in Constantinople and they codified what
they thought were the right principles
of law which then replaced this huge
mess these mounds of centuries of
judicial decisions and that
recodification by all accounts sparked
an incredible commercial renaissance in
the ancient world because people
actually could have understood what
their obligations were they actually
trusted law more it became it was more
and it became the basis for the legal
systems of Western Europe for over a
thousand years and then it became
inevitably overly complicated itself and
the great accomplishment of Napoleon was
was a Napoleonic Code same thing he had
three or four people with pointy hats
told them to create a new system he
created a civil code of general
principles like do what's reasonable in
the circumstances
it's for actually good faith these
things don't tell you how to do things
but they're basic principles again and
that system is still the basis of the
civil law countries which in many areas
have more reliable law than we do
we probably have the most reliable
commercial law because in the 1950s a
bunch of scholars created something
called the Uniform Commercial Code a set
of principles adopted by all the states
which gives us the most reliable system
of contract law you don't allow juries
to decide whether or not you know a
contract was fair or know that the
contract didn't work out I should get my
money back you have a system of
principles that don't allow juries even
to hear that so there are all kinds of
examples of what happens when you when
you Rico defy law and how it changes the
society they're not funny stories
unfortunately I'm sorry the Barrett
their anecdote doesn't necessarily mean
I mean Napoleon was kind of a funny guy
actually I mean in his own way
yeah do we need to worry that Justinian
and Napoleon or Emperor's well there is
that advantage yeah
but you know we've we've made changes
look at the rights revolution we've made
in the Progressive Era this is not much
different than that one question came in
anonymously how do you define
accountability you lose your job it's a
little more okay I'd say a little more
in in a job context accountability means
the negative things happen to you
because you didn't do the job well or
you acted like a jerk or whatever was so
it depends on what the nature of the of
the of the omission or Commission was
but but in any sensible organization
someone who doesn't show up to work on a
consistent basis will lose their job
that actually is not true with
government I was in the army
and the dealer is different yeah deal
well it is a government organization you
probably know that it's very socialistic
prostate and the deal there is a
commander is responsible for all
everything that his unit does and fails
to do and you can't usually fire people
but boy you can move them around right
yeah you know the sergeant is not
delivering gets demoted and a lot of
people especially lately have been
through the military process under
combat conditions where it really counts
life and death and all that is this a
body of people that have this
understanding about behavior that we can
now deploy in society well I think the
military is is unique because it's the
military but the military is highly
functioning in times of crisis in other
words people in the field are trained
not to follow rules in fact all the all
the military manuals tell you that if
you worry about following rules you're
likely to be the loser in the in the war
game you have to constantly adapt to the
circumstance in front of you so they're
trained actually to do the opposite of
being bureaucratic in the field now I'm
told in the Pentagon it works a little
differently but it's true yeah but in a
peacetime yeah and maybe in peacetime it
works but the people I know have been in
the military have a very strong sense of
duty and they have a pretty clear sense
of accountability there's a sense of
career professionalism was sort of an
idea that was introduced a while back in
the military and lawyers and doctors
have this the whole idea of the
professionalism you have a duty a sense
of responsibility to your calling does
that help in this kind of thing yes I
mean culture always helps and
professionalism helps one of the things
has happened I happen to be a lawyer on
I apologize the no no the the you've
gotta stop it
we gotta stuff lawyers apologizing right
they should be proud of you fired lately
exactly but what was the question here
what was the question a little crowd
sourcing here
well professionalism my profession sock
see I mean there is no deer the live
used to be to get into a good bar
association you actually had to have
people write letters about your values
which included fair citations of cases
and briefs and all the other aspects of
a professional lawyer where you were you
you fought fairly you accurately stated
the facts now you would try to shade
them for your client that's what lawyers
do
but you weren't miss stating the facts
and there was a line there you wouldn't
go across you would be through now to
get into the same Bar Association's all
you have to prove is you have a law
degree and you've never been indicted I
mean there is no sense of professional
standards and sure enough in briefs that
you see that go to court
I see weekly so-called respectable law
firms miss citing cases
miss miss describing facts in ways that
are not arguable so I'm afraid
professionalism in at least in the law
profession and perhaps in others is
degenerated in part because of all the
things we've been talking so it's just
barring dropped away is it harder to get
disbarred now than it used to be you you
really only get disbarred for for crimes
it's very hard does that always been the
case or is that just what it devolved
you know I think he's probably always
been the case okay a question from
Alexander Rose should we limit the
number of laws at each level of
government then you have to vote one law
out for every law in where there is this
kind of is it a it's a lot like a FIFO
since there
you know that there is this kind of idea
that for every new law there should be a
you know one taken off the books you
know again my sense is that what's more
important than the actual number of laws
is as I said is how the laws are written
and whether they allow people to use
their judgment in implementation but but
I'm you know almost any procedural
device that would make legislators do
what they don't do today let's just go
back and revisit all laws I think it's a
good idea so just a requirement that how
about that the authors of the bill have
to be able to recite it aloud without
notes oh boy that would be a great one
imagine there are people who would be
able to do the 250 page laws that way
but not many yeah
question from Jeremy looks like Canfield
will shifting the common sense laws
required good judgement there for
interpretation also shift the balance of
power from legislative branch to the
interpretive branch namely the judges
could the judges undo all this
legislative fixing you do that's very
interesting there were you know there
are three players here the the executive
the legislature and the judges right now
everybody is kind of stuck in this dense
legal web and they can't and they're all
sort of playing games within the web but
they can't really act in in in my vision
implementation is with the executive but
they have to answer to the to the
legislature I didn't talk about courts
today although I gave a TED talk that
talks a lot about judges if people want
to hear that but it's actually an
important part of this that judges
actually constantly draw lines about who
can sue for what and they should they
can't allow disagreements between the
legislature in the administrative branch
to get decided
in court there's a kind of paper covers
rock here and so Congress is in charge
of making legislative programs and the
executive branch implementing it if the
legislative branch doesn't like it it
can change the law and bring them
executive back into it the courts really
shouldn't have much to do with it so
would you like to see the courts
basically playing less of a role in the
service well I would play less of a role
when it comes to legislative judgments
there are plenty of roles that judges
the courts are gonna have to play
inevitably because they're gonna be
standards like was there a good-faith
interpretation or again in my vision the
only thing that would be Justitia before
an environmental impact statement was
whether somebody created the
environmental impact statement or
evaluated it basically in bad faith
uh-huh that still requires some judicial
overseer to make that judgment so courts
would have a role and many of these in
in an application in a particular case
and you know you don't want to give up
the opportunity to go to court for the
extreme case when somebody really does
abuse their authority but judges have to
be mindful that they're not supposed to
reconsider every legislative judgment
they're only there to to basically judge
the outer boundaries of reasonable
behavior you mentioned the Omnibus
sunset law basically all laws shut down
to a certain point have to be revisited
rewritten or let go is so that's the
kind of the schedule on the back end and
but then you talk about the 20 years it
takes to get wind generators out in the
waters off of Cape Cod is there the
possible and so a lot of this is
scheduled and with infrastructure
especially once you get it going you
know you're just losing money every day
that you're not actually digging ground
and bending steel so is there reason and
maybe this happens sometimes where the
law says and this shall be implemented
in three years time or something like
that can you do that
sure you can do that and there are
deadlines in laws from from from time to
time does it work
sometimes but I mean when the when the
Southern California or no so that's
other when the California earthquake
mm-hmm 89 89 they basically waived all
those all the requirements for
procurement laws environmental reviews
all these laws basically got got waived
or accelerated and as a result of which
you had I think it was a Santa Monica
freeway got rebuilt in it was up and
running again in a matter of months it
would have taken five years or eight
years yeah and we got the Bay Bridge
rebuilt in a year's time yeah the same
thing no one years and complete won't be
for a few more now it's so that's a
classic case actually of and my friend
Jerry Brown was one that once helped
slow that down by you know aesthetically
saying it was not as pretty as a
chipping lots of things slowed it down
but you know what happens with these
slowing down is the cost multiplies many
times over every time well once you're
implementing right and one of the things
that makes World's Fairs sometimes work
in fact critical path planning / charts
and so on first came into public with
the Montreal World's Fair back in the
60s which was brought in on schedule and
on budget because it was somebody who
knew how to do that kind of planning
that was leadership of his authority was
all the things you're speaking of there
was also an expert there was a real
deadline right yeah it was going to open
on a date certain right well that well
but you know having the deadline is the
best but the next best is having
officials they have the authority to say
go you know if you have requirement
environmental review and it's a wind
farm and wind farms are not all that
different from each other you know
they're slightly different they're not
that different right I mean they do have
environmental impacts but they're not
that different from each other somebody
can look at the effects in this side us
without spending years doing it uh-huh
you know it doesn't it doesn't so so if
you have someone with the authority to
say go and that's only subject to to
judicial review if it's exercised in bad
faith where they're clearly just
ignoring the impact then you can have
something start to be built in a year
how do you detect bad faith it's all a
matter of judgment and the facts and
there's nothing in anything I talked
about whether it's how you run a
classroom how you interpret bad faith
whether it's a significant whether the
environmental risk is worth the benefit
or none of those things all of these
things involve human judgment and you
can have on important decisions checks
and balances on it but somebody has to
exercise the judgment if you try to
create a system that's hands-free which
is what we've done what we get is a
system that's paralyzed some questions
of what it takes to change and you
mentioned the earthquake that sort of
moved things along in some areas
Don Kendall says interest groups will
never allow such a wholesale
restructuring of our laws and rules the
only force capable of overwhelming
objections is imminent bankruptcy that
help absolutely there's nothing like
bankruptcy the you know history tells
you the times of big change only happens
in times of crisis so there is a
likelihood that the nothing I talked
about just to be realistic about it it's
going to happen until people really feel
they're about to plunge over the cliff
and the advantage of trying to build a
coalition and a movement to reorganize
government to be solvent and such is it
allows when that happens the government
to land at a place that's responsible
you don't have what might be happening
in Tunisia or what happened in the
Soviet Union so you get one group of
people who push for change and then
before they know it they're out to
and you get all these lunatics running
the you know running the society so
that's a likelihood of what will happen
if we wait till a crisis we have no
ideas we'll get some lunatics who wind
up coming you know some Sarah Palin type
will end up coming into power I know
you're all supportive to Sarah Palin too
along with your tea party credentials
but the you you'll have some lunatic who
will have all these crazy ideas about
quote deregulation or so if it won't
work at all
why did the American Revolution be a
pretty much conservative responsibility
taking revolution where the people who
started stuck with it right through it
and the French Revolution very similar
somewhat different situation but
drastically different process where
exactly what you described happen the
French were all related to Sarah Palin
you know France I'm actually just
reading a book a three-volume set 3,000
pages why and doing this it's great for
going to sleep on the Hundred Years War
and and this this this flip in through
feudal culture of being completely
subservient to the people in power you
know as long as they have shiny helmets
and they were around that said but when
they felt weak going in and killing him
it's just part of that culture and
that's what happened in 1789 Americans
were where didn't want that kind of
authority they had a they had a town
government they they basically had
invented a form of democracy it was a it
was it was sort of an aristocracy but it
was a democratic aristocracy who are
founders basically and and that's the
values that they adhered to it wasn't
one of let's topple the king they did
topple the king but what they wanted was
not a new king they wanted to have their
town meetings become the basis of a new
Union
so they were growing at the draw
attention to something which I hadn't
really thought of which is the written
the colonies were separate and
separately organized Pennsylvania was a
different thing than Massachusetts and
they weren't the United States yet there
were a bunch of states trying various
things and arguing and occasionally
having a little bit of interstate
commerce and stuff like that but by and
large they were going different paths
and started to have a range of choices
that people already had experience and
working it which was not the case in
Paris at all 1988 1789 so yeah well so
now we have 50 states and they have many
counties in those counties have many
towns and so there is a place where
things get tried that you don't have to
bet the whole goddamn country on you can
bet one state at a time theoretically
but that you know that that range of
motion has been restricted by this by
this legal system that tries to
prescribe not only that you must provide
these services but how you must provide
the services one of the terrible things
about modern law is it makes it
impossible not impossible very difficult
for people to make a difference so if
you're a retired person in a community
where there's a need for hospice care
for people who are older where there's a
need for tutors for kids and stuff the
bureaucracy you have to go through to
perform any of those functions is enough
to basically dissuade many people from
doing that and whereas in our founders
time there would be zero you would just
go help out so well we adorn raisings
and all that kind of stuff you know
people just helped the the term for what
you're describing is subsidiarity right
something that World Bank and so on if
you know we're gonna give money to this
country you've got to push not try to
run the towns from the country
government there any any decision that
can be made at a lower level should be
made at a lower
okay so first decisions down to the
ground and this is supposedly what Jerry
Brown now is trying to do with with some
of our state money is that the money and
the authority to do the right thing with
it is going to the counties into the
cities this is something you approve of
sounds like yeah absolutely the more the
more human freedom the more individual
responsibility in my world the better
doesn't mean you don't give up big
public goals uh-huh but if Tocqueville
had a wonderful line once he said I'm
much something to the effect if I much
fear more the taking away of my freedom
and daily choices to implement then I do
some dictator telling me you know what
my goals are because it's when I can't
actually make things happen that I
really feel the constraints of tyranny
and I no longer you know full as a
person and all of that it's it's this
web that presses down into daily choices
that's a far more insidious invasion of
freedom than telling somebody they've
got to pay 50% of taxes and sound a 36%
in taxes or whatever there's a
behavioral thing here customized neal
cassady I knew back in the day that's
and Merry Pranksters and all of that
said there's only one sin fretting and
fretting is a national pastime
especially in parts of government and my
fellow environmentalists are wonderful
at fretting we can imagine more things
that can go wrong with this that or the
other thing that anybody and we will
yeah we bang on various legislators and
judges and so on to be sure that our
frets don't come true and a previous
speaker here was Jimmy Wales who said
this is the his software that he Bruns
Wikipedia and a lot of a software people
were spending a lot of their time
designing for problems that they
anticipated would occur with the system
and he said that's crazy
because that's like a guy who runs a
restaurant
saying well we're gonna serve steak but
steak involves steak knives and some of
our customers might stab each other and
so we'll have to put cages around each
of the tables and then we can go ahead
and serve steak knives I never thought
about yeah well you know Fisheries
problem I want many a law many judicial
finding has the quality of what people
might stab each other with these steak
knives and therefore we gotta make it
illegal to yeah blah blah blah so
fretting you could go to the stand-up
comedy part of this routine where we
talking about what's happened to
playgrounds and warning labels and do a
[ __ ] you know our playground we I
mean there is nothing left in
playgrounds for a kid over the age of
four nothing you know seesaw jungle gyms
climbing ropes merry-go-rounds or been
gone there are a few diving boards left
but not many not very many high boards
why is that they all involved not just
the risk but the certainty something
might go wrong
they also happen to attract kids to the
playground so they don't get fat and die
of obesity say awesome okay they also
they they also happen to teach kids how
to take responsibility for themselves
and and to be I think they're all these
things that those risks are vital for
child development for which the American
Academy of Pediatrics and all kinds of
other boring people would write books
about but we don't have a legal system
that allows people to take the risk of
allowing kids to take the ordinary risk
of childhood it's lunacy so what it's
complete lunacy what's another example
of what's you know wrong with this
what's the measure of acceptable risk
the values of what a reasonable people
person would consider at our time a
model-t was reasonably safe in 1910 it
would not be reasonably safe today our
values have changed that's fine and so
in the case of children's play we happen
to have people who study dr. Stewart
Brown down in the valley runs the
institute of play you know there are all
these really important people who've
actually
studied the importance of children's
playing what the scope of it should be
and that can help define what reasonable
risks for children is the range of
exploration of a nine-year-old and
America has sought has decried declined
by over 90 percent since 1970 kids are
not allowed to leave home by themselves
and that ability to wander around the
neighborhood to explore the creek all
that sort of thing is absolutely vital
to the interest level the guy who's in
charge of obesity at the Center for
Disease Control so we wouldn't have a
problem of obesity if kids simply did
what they did 30 years ago
because kids just get out and do things
they were active now part of the problem
is caused by you because me you yeah
you've created this industry here in
this part of the world with game boys
and all kinds of other stuff so the kids
sit in there you know they're transfixed
by their electronic gear that you made
but but that's not the only problem it's
also illegal from you think there should
be a law against you should apologize
I'm apologize for your lawyer you should
apologize sure a question always comes
up in all of these things it's what
about China I'm gonna be following
nuclear stuff long ok it's really yeah
so you know Westinghouse has had an
ap1000 1.2 gigawatt very safe generation
3 plus reactor ready to go for 10 to 15
years and it'll probably be another 10
years before I once built the US China
is building for 8 P 1000s as we speak
and now some people say the difference
is at least it for the present the
Politburo consists almost entirely of
people were trained either scientists or
engineers we have approximately none of
those in a truly senior office here
except by appointment right is this the
difference or what's going on is they
just you know his channel like we were
Teddy Roosevelt days a hundred years ago
and you call off the all kinds
things well I think there is an aspect
of that they're also a totalitarian
regime which allows them to make those
choices we're back agreeing in the poll
you know right but the same risk of bad
judgments that has driven us to to you
know this lousy legal system is also
driven us away from in this case my view
is environmentally important
technologies that have downsides to them
but on balance I think are very
important like nuclear power I actually
got my start working at Oakridge when I
was a kid for a Nobel Prize winner
called Eugene's big nurse for three
numbers so I'm not scared of nuclear
power I understand it a little bit and
and I think it's a tragedy you know 20%
of the electric electricity generated in
this country comes from nuclear power
and we haven't built a nuclear power
plant and how many decades and three
three yeah and so they're all gonna go
out of service so what are we gonna do
we replace them with coal Kevin I see
you're on your way up here which is good
because I have a question for you want
to grab that mic right there by the
front of the podium we're talking about
China and you've just been in China you
said everybody talked to you in China
was complaining about the government and
you know Here I am sort of valorizing
the Chinese government what are they
complaining about and does it yeah well
I don't know if it feeds into it but
just because you've shanghaied me here
so to speak I was in China and I was
meeting with a lot of people in Beijing
and I met with I probably talked to
close to a hundred people and I would
say that every single one of them
without exception was visibly audibly
publicly complaining about the
government including the people who
worked in the government and they were
complaining about almost a very similar
thing is is that there was no process
for them to accomplish little things
it's something if something was wrong
they noticed that they there there was
no process for the
- no one to complain - to appeal -
because the whole the whole apparatus
was sort of invisible opaque and so
their frustration level was was tangible
and they were basically telling me
something was going to change in the
next couple of years they didn't know
what but they felt that the the this
sort of inability these impotency to
actually make change happen in a way
that they could initiate and it wasn't
not talking about overthrow the
government we're talking about solving
the traffic problem in Beijing or
solving some of the environmental
problems there was nothing that they
knew how to start can they do anything
locally in government there the gut
there is local government that can be
effective but again it's there's not
people that you elect who is it there's
somebody who works there who they
responds to and they really taking
orders from it's all unclear it's it's
some appointment by somebody that
doesn't really have any accountability
basically they're accountable not to any
of the citizens and so this there is a
very similar kind of frustration I don't
know if the the remedy is the same if
you would say well the remedy is the
same in both cases individuals law
clerks have to have accountability but
there's certainly the similar
frustration so I don't think China is
any kind of a model for what we want to
go well China's certainly not a model in
other ways I mean there's no contract
law that's any good in China and
ultimately that's going to come to bite
it I mean right now it's incredible
efficiency and devalued because currency
allows it to do lots of deals and
everybody wants to do it or they get
products for cheap but when people
ignore their contracts don't pay up on
contracts or a pay only 65% long term
you can't you can't maintain a economic
base that way if I see one of the things
I was thinking about when you were
describing the difficulty of like
starting a small business without just
automatically breaking the law that this
may be what drives people into the
informal basically lawless economy
in many parts of the world i'm cholena
probably here much of which is crime of
course now one of the advantages of
crime is you don't have to ask anybody's
permission no bureaucracy I mean the
whole idea of organized crime on the
other hand is that there is bureaucracy
and probably it sucks well as Hernando
de Soto who did those studies in Peru
about the black market the bureaucracy
was so dense in Peru that decreed is
incredibly vital economy all the taxis
were gypsy cabs all the everything was
black market and they created a parallel
economy that actually ended up being a
pretty good economy that was completely
ultra or ex legal it's you know instead
of outside the before the code the
formal formal legal system was so
dysfunctional and finally people are
showing the study the informal economy
and see how it works one of the things
is it involves everybody having to know
each other here's a question from Danny
Hillis if more resources were shifted
from federal to state and local
governments subsidiarity
with fixing government be easier or
harder I think easier the closer you get
to the ground the easier it is I mean a
lot of people in this room are gonna
know gavin newsom if he has more
authorities not bound by mandates and
stuff you can actually put more pressure
on him it's but one of the things that
what we're talking about it what makes
it hard is a lot of what needs to change
has to be changed in Washington uh-huh
many of the mandates that make it
impossible to balance budget or man and
Medicaid and other mandates
for special ed mandates that come from
Washington they're unfunded mandates so
we have to go to Washington to change it
so does it work up luckily you had Nancy
Pelosi here and she's who she is see a
little more about that sure okay suppose
cities get themselves squared away
counties get themselves squared away
does that work upward or does it stop
there I think you can work upward you
know ultimately
lots of people have said this you know
we get the government we deserve culture
Trump's even special interests cultural
Trump special interest means special
interest rate what makes it one thing we
didn't talk about but it's worth coming
on here is that our founders never
anticipated this problem they didn't
understand that it would be a hundred
times harder to unmake a law than to
make a law they thought that the process
would be just a lawmaking process and
the factions would balance each other
out Federalist and Madison and such and
then we would get some reasonable
approximation of something that
democracy thought made sense at that
moment well in fact it doesn't work that
way once a law is created once the law
is created whatever or special interests
like the law unites around it and so
every law has an army of special
interests around it and to get one word
of that law changed a majority of
Congress each has to run a gauntlet of
those special interests that's why it's
unthinkably difficult like that they
recently it recently came at the ethanol
subsidy which is environmentally
destructive seven point seven billion
dollars a year it's just a freebie to
you know some companies in that business
right so and it had a sunset clause so
to show that that's not a cure-all the
ethanol subsidy subset sunsetted on
December 31st 2010 so there was a big
debate in in the fall with Republican
fiscal Hawks going up against the
Republicans and the Democrats from the
farm states right and it looked like
finally something good was going to
happen helped by the sunset laws well
god bless him a deal was made on some
other deep provision that extended the
ethanol subsidies for another couple of
years I mean
it's here we are in the middle of a
fiscal crisis you could take a vote of
the members of Congress and 98% of them
would say it's a complete waste of money
and they extended it this is a system
that's broken
Peter Shrek tell that was a question how
do you see technology and changing
government in the future Moore's laws
gonna apply another 50 years it looks
like tech communication tech especially
is moving right along to change
government absolutely I think technology
recently there was a report in New York
State about a crisis of civil legal
services for the indigent and it told a
story of of literally 2 million cases a
year the New York State courts of people
who can't afford lawyers but who have
real life problems or landlord tenant
problems are being evicted their family
law problems with custody their creditor
Kurla collection cases so these are real
problems for these people they can't
afford a lawyer they go to the regular
court system it's completely packed they
can't possibly negotiate it it's
terrible for the other side too there
you know the judge ended up reading 8
postponements because people can't
follow the rules they're not lawyers
after all and so the judge was going to
call for hundreds of millions of dollars
of funding to hire more lawyers to
represent these people I mean New York
state's bankrupt this kind of give a
hundreds of million dollars to lawyers
to represent not even there's no chance
so they sent me the draft report and
that's what I think I say well what I
think is you need to completely change
the system you need to create a system
of ombudsman using technology to keep
track of everything that's going on with
every landlord and every family so you
don't have to go back to the same judge
all the time you have like it's like a
patient database except it would be a
database for all these disputes mm-hm
and if you have a database that you
build up over time of all these disputes
you can actually have ombudsman that
actually can reasonably competently hear
the story figure out who's playing games
and who's not and so the the info
revolution actually provides a mechanism
for beginning to provide services that
people really need in a semi at least
reliable way because they can see how
the whole so for example if there's a
landlord
who's an abusive landlord it'll pop up
on the screen that's it then
you know all these other cases have come
up so it's not bound by the laws of
evidence it doesn't have the rulings of
law it's just a decision in these
essentially small claims type cases of
great importance to the people involved
in them and technology can do them well
there's a funny mismatch the technology
moves pretty rapidly we're talking about
the you know procurement process that
means that you get a computer that's
five generations behind and famously
people here have lived in the outlaw
area of cutting-edge technology that the
laws won't catch up with the law you
know the legislators won't even be aware
of for five or ten years so we get to
probably privacy laws are a significant
problem say more privacy laws are way
behind well we have privacy laws that
that assume a kind of an idealized
system where we're there where you don't
have all this information moving
automatically around the web it's really
on it's completely unrealistic and so
you need to have some kind of
materiality mechanism or intent
mechanism for violating privacy because
in many respects it's basically
impossible for companies providing
certain kinds of services effectively to
quote honor privacy in the sense of
being completely invisible and all that
so privacy laws are also a problem
because they're one of the reasons why
these maniacs like the guy who just shot
everybody in Arizona don't get called on
the carpet in the case of the Virginia
Tech shooter a few years ago he was
known by the clinicians among others on
campus to be a threat but they thought
it would violate his rights to privacy
if they called up other people and tell
them so he went and murdered 35 people I
mean it's it's you know there's this you
know again it's a service of these
ideals that aren't really realistic and
in in modern society we're all living
together you really do need to have
these open lines of communication I can
see the fast-moving technology we're
going to keep renegotiating whatever the
social contract is trying to be with
privacy for years yes we will and and
that's natural just like our views of
auto safety change and everything else
and sometimes they go too far and they
need to be pulled back okay a big final
question from Cynthia is there a
standard common sense
I know it's implied how common is really
said or whatever I think no you know
people you know they're there there's a
wonderful book by Robert Wright a few
years ago called the moral animal who
said isn't it amazing what a what a
perfect record of good judgment each of
us has and but of course a lesson that
every child learns watching her parents
is that there are there can be very many
different views on the same issue so
common sense is whatever somebody
believes in their training is make sense
in the circumstances and it can be in
the same situation there can be very
many sensible solutions but what the
studies also tell us is if people
believe that they are free to do what
they believe is right we're going to end
up this I think this is appropriate in
dealing with this child in the classroom
whatever it is or in this particular
wind farm that's a good thing if you
make people believe that they have to
justify their decisions in a kind of
legalistic way can you
prove that you can you prove that Johnny
through the pencil first for the teacher
or whatever you make people make worse
judgments you drive them from the smart
part of their brain where they're
focusing on how do I make something
happen to this kind of thin veneer of
conscious logic but people are saying
how will I justify that I did this and
pretty soon or as Michael Polanyi wrote
a book about this called personal
knowledge great book from 1950 said a
pianist can't play the piece if she's
thinking about how she's hitting the
notes if you make somebody self
conscious they actually can't
in many cases use good judgment and so
common sense is people doing whatever's
in them they will succeed or fail and in
my world on balance they will be held
accountable not for every failure but on
balance for how good a job they do and
so there's no such thing as the right
answer the reason we got in this mess we
thought there was a right answer there
is no right answer freedom is not an
instruction manual it's an argument it's
it's it's no it's a hypothesis this is a
negotiation well no it's a hypothesis I
believe this is right you believe that's
right if we both have to agree we'll
we'll come up with the solution if I'm
in charge which is my preferred position
I simply I simply make a decision and
I'm accountable to somebody who's in
charge of me but well it famously where
does good judgment come it comes from
experience where does experience come
from bad judgment
there's a trial in there your app
completely so how do you learn in life
from error okay from saying things that
are inappropriate even I haven't learned
that lesson but most people and and and
trial and error definitely this is the
path to all success requires error it
requires a tolerance for error it
requires giving people the chance to air
and the chance to lose their job and if
they're really bad at it
to lose their job but in any sensible
system you're judging people on you know
on balance in other words so teachers
will make mr. L we all make mistakes all
the time the question is are we on
balance good at what we do whereas we
have a system today that assumes it's a
kind of perfection is this phony
perfection and it's whatever the
rulebook says and the rulebook in fact
is central planning it's lousy it causes
failure in the name of uniformity it's
not what freedom was supposed to be and
and the terror of modern government is
we've turned it into something we've
asked it to do all these really
important jobs and we've asked all these
really good people who got many you know
many good people spend their lives in
government if you're trying to do what
to make the bus system work or whatever
and we've given them impossible
conditions or very difficult conditions
to do that
it sounds like part of what you want is
the there's a kind of an action oriented
make something happen you know you learn
from the mistakes as you go if you spend
all of your time and cover your ass mode
with the bureaucracy and very little
time in making something happen then the
system grinds to a halt but if you can
somehow move that balance toward make
something happen of course cover your
ass but don't do it as a full-time job
is what we're asking our culture this
shift to push make something yeah I
think so and you know four important
judgments you wouldn't want to I have
this argument with the head of the
teachers union
I'm not saying give the principal
unfettered discretion to fire any
teacher uh-huh let's have a site based
committee of parents and teachers who
have a veto power it's just not a legal
proceeding it's not all these things are
matters of judgment it's not a matter of
proof so presumptively the teacher the
principal ought to be able to manage the
school if he's making a decision for
some horrible reason because he didn't
get sexual favors from the teacher or or
because he's just as a hang-up but
everybody else loves the teacher his
decision in my world could be vetoed
but it's quite efficient it's his
judgment with a veto power because we've
decided that's an important judgment
it's fine it's still a matter of
judgment you still move forward today
there's no decision being made and the
result is we get to the other part you
know all the teachers find themselves
trapped in this you know horrific
horrific bureaucracy filling out forms
all night long so everybody here wants
to change the system everybody outside
the room wants to change the system does
it take bankruptcy first or climate
change or will it be done piecemeal or
as a bloody revolution and and what's it
take to make anything happen
political science say that change like
this does not happen incrementally it
happens in big bites the branch breaks
it that's what happened in the rights
revolution that's what happened in the
Progressive Era people worked for years
to make those things happen
but they happened in a relatively small
period of time in Egypt as a groundswell
plus some strong leadership is that
right yes so that combination to change
of values you and so in this case we do
need leadership and we need leaders and
we're talking but you know we have a lot
of people who are generally respected
the AL Simpsons and Bill Bradley's or
the world who are part of our group but
it takes more than that we really do
require you know we're we need the
active citizen citizen leaders heads of
Rotary clubs business leaders to come
together behind this idea we need to
create a movement that's why we've hired
these people to create this new web home
for the beginnings of this movement
because you can't just talk about it you
can't rob it's just right up at it you
know I write it all the time you can't
just write about it and talk about it
you need people to get together and to
corner political leaders and say you
have to do this and if you don't I'm not
going to support you and I'm going to
support somebody who is going to do this
okay so to make a movement get momentum
and need some early victories what's an
early victory
that's achievable well I'm not sure you
do need early victories what were the
early victories of the civil rights
movement so you know we have a proposal
that in healthcare to create special
health courts that everybody's for the
consumer groups to victims rights groups
all the doctors President Obama wrote a
letter in favor of it earlier in the
year and it's not happening why is it
not happening because it's a b-level
wonky it's a good but b-level wonky
reform proposal and there's one interest
group the trial lawyers that gives 50
million dollars to the Democratic Party
and so whoever your Congress person is
in this district I've forgotten her name
and Harry Reid refused to let the
bipartisan proposals to do special
health courts supported by everybody in
health care every legitimate interests
in health care be part of the bill and
so so somebody you know what so I okay
so what's the emotional that that's be
level walkie what's a level emotional
people who can get behind oh I think I
think if we completely deep your D
bureaucratized schools restored a
culture of order and respect which means
you get rid of all the kind of rules of
around hearings and all that kind of
stuff you have different safeguards you
bulldoze the bureaucracy and you create
an effective accountability mechanism
that that formula even if you just did
it in a couple of schools would be
transformative completely would be
completely transformative and and and
there's another that's and that could be
done largely locally yeah you know
unlike some of these other things which
require federalism and it is emotional
it is long-term because you're talking
about the next generation okay that's a
good let's fix the schools thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]